this is the VHS for an extremely goofy
movie it's a follow up to the cult
classic a goofy movie and it's one of my
favorite animated films now there's a
moment in this movie where Bobby
zamorski Max's stoner friend you know
the one that Chuck's cheese whiz he says
do you ever wonder why we're always like
wearing gloves that's a damn good
question Bobby let's figure this out
[Music]
does the question why do animated
characters wear gloves come up a lot for
you
the question rarely comes up but when it
does there are a number of answers to it
that's John cane maker he's an animation
historian and professor at NYU miss
basic theory is that glove save time at
the dawn of animation everything was
hand drawn over and over and over again
and certain techniques to make the
process more efficient shape the style
of the cartoons as Felix was becoming
more popular the animator Bill Nolan
decided to remove his snout and make him
more circular overall what they called
the rubber hose encircled spaghetti
characters this rubber hose encircle
aesthetic allowed animators to quickly
draw arms legs and hands without
spending too much time developing
realistic details of the characters body
like elbows and knees a round edge was
much faster to draw than an angle and
that certainly applied to hands with all
those little fingers and Knuckles but
hands posed another problem for
animators in the age of fuzzy
black-and-white film characters were in
black-and-white films difficult to see
against their black body take a look at
Mickey Mouse in 1927 is playing crazy he
had black hands and feet just like Felix
he gained shoes in 1928 Steamboat Willie
and in 1929 he's wearing gloves
the Opera House the rubber-hose style of
animation is in full effect here every
character is exaggerated round and
simple and like many of the glove
wearing cartoon characters of his time
Mickey Mouse is a non human doing very
human things in his 1968 biography the
Disney version Walt Disney addresses
this very issue he says we didn't want
him to have Mouse hands because he was
supposed to be more human so we gave him
gloves so in addition to saving time and
providing color contrast gloves bring
non-human things to life making their
grand gestures stand out these 1935
teakettles from vampyre and studios have
them this movie camera does too when
Pinocchio is a puppet he wears gloves
but when he becomes a boy they disappear
they're no longer needed but there's
another less practical influence behind
cartoon characters white gloves the
Opera House is a film about Mickey
putting on a big vaudeville show that
film and many of the animations that
predated it were inextricably linked to
vaudeville performance and the blackface
minstrel shows of the time in fact early
animators often performed on vaudeville
stages Nicholas salmon writes in birth
of an industry that early animated
characters like Felix a cat Bembo Bosco
and Mickey Mouse weren't just like
minstrels they were minstrels both the
cartoons and the stage characters were
portrayed as mischievous and rebellious
yet good-natured they wore loose clothes
had painted faces and they wore white
gloves in the 1930s vaudeville and
blackface minstrelsy declined white
gloves were no longer associated with
vaudeville to a new generation of
viewers instead they were just part of
the cartoon style people came to expect
there was also in the band concert do
you know that film
it's from 1935 one of the characters is
a cow characters called Clarabelle cow
and she plays the flute and her glove
gets stuck in the past
so really tricky without the glove 60
years later
goofy takes off his gloves before
getting in a pool and it's frankly
really disturbing now what's really
bothering me is why Daffy Duck and many
other animated birds don't wear gloves
we might never know look let's not split
hairs why do you even wear a glove
because I've always worn them it's Who I
am why do you wear that thing around
your neck
Touche Bugs Bunny Touche
[Music]